what is up everybody it's 414 anime here
for anime or Pro and today we are going
to be talking about how Ichigo could be
the next Soul King Ichigo is very unique
in the fact that he is a hybrid of
Shinigami Hollow and Quincy Heritage
which may land him with not only the
title of the next Soul King but what
comes with that title in its horrendous
fate we have made a load of bleach
videos on the channel now including an
hour-long video covering ichigo's power
so make sure to check that video out
after this one link to that is in the
video description now if you do enjoy
these bleach videos on the channel and
you'd like to see more you know what to
do smash that like button as it really
does help us out with that YouTube
algorithm if you haven't already make
this the video that you subscribe and
hit that notification Bell to turn on
all notifications you can also follow us
on Twitter and Instagram at anime or
brawl and now without further Ado let's
jump into It spoilers and all the soul
King also known as the king of all Souls
is a central figure in the Bleach anime
and manga series The Soul King is said
to be the source of All Souls and the
ruler of the Soul Society the afterlife
in which the Soul Reapers reside the
soul King is also the guardian of
balance in the universe ensuring that
the flow of souls between the living
world and the sole Society remain in
Balance the soul King is a complex and
mysterious figure and its true nature
and purpose are shrouded in mystery
however its role as the source of All
Souls and the guardian of balance in the
universe make it a central and important
figure in the series its history and the
events surrounding it have had profound
impact on the lives of many of the
characters and its Fate has shaped the
course of the series entirely now the
soul King is first introduced to us in
chapter
223 but we don't actually get to see a
full glimpse of this intriguing being
way up until chapter 519 our first look
at the soul King is a very interesting
one it is just a silhouette of a fully
humanoid looking figure that is encased
within a yellow Crystal however when we
later see him we can see that the soul
King is in fact a limbless and lifeless
corpse trapped within that Crystal that
we had just mentioned this raises the
question you know was the soul King once
intact losing his limbs over time or was
Kubo just unsure on the soul King's
design at that specific time well that
question is answered however not in the
manga but instead in the bleach light
novel entitled can't fear your own world
the history of the Soul King is also
shrouded in mystery and little is known
about its origins or its true purpose
some people believe that the soul King
is a deity While others see it as a
powerful force of nature however in this
light novel we found out more no not
only about the soul King and his
importance in the bleach universe but
also Snippets of his history many years
ago before the current events in the
story The World of bleach as we know it
was completely different in our current
time the world is made up of three
different Realms that being the world of
the living the soul society and Waco
Mundo these three Realms are what the
soul King keeps in Balance so that the
world does not regress to what it once
was a world in which both life and death
were one in the same it was a world
completely unstable and an absolute
living chaos Hollows eventually entered
this world and started hunting down and
eating the humans who inhabited it in
doing so the hollows upset the balance
and the flow of Souls which eventually
led to the birth of the first menos the
world back then was a place in which
everything existed together the hollows
preyed on the humans who had literally
nowhere safe to live and The Souls of
the daily departed also had nowhere ago
it was otter Mayhem and a true living
hell however a powerful being would
emerge from this chaos to fight for the
humans this man was so powerful that he
could take down these menos classed
Hollows with ease turning them into
reishi sand this man would later become
none other than the soul King now ichibe
the leader of the now zero division was
also around at this time and he actually
remarked that there was nothing and no
one in this world that was equal to the
soul King in terms of his raw power now
even though the soul King was in a sense
the savior of the humans in defending
them and seeing off the hollows he was
actually continuing the destabilization
of the balance within this world as the
hollows he was destroying were being
eradicated rather than purified this
means that the soul of that Hollow would
fade away from existence thus upsetting
the very fragile and unstable balance of
this world now to put an end into this
on balance and to finally restore
stability five powerful beings came
together with a solution these five
individuals who are actually the
ancestors of the five Great noble
families work together to portray the
soul King each of these individuals
though sharing the same goal of bringing
balance to the world each had their own
way of wanting to go about it including
its outcomes they however came up with a
conclusion that not only ticked off
their main goal but their individual
ones too what they wanted to do was to
split the world up into three different
Realms that would bring about a much
needed cycle of life and death but in
order to do that they needed a power
that the soul King himself possessed
called The Almighty a power that of
course would be passed down to his son
who was none other than johar ba so not
only did the almighty have the power to
see all Futures and change them as he so
you know wished to but he also had the
power to split worlds and this was the
power that the five individuals wanted
they Enlisted the help of none other
than ichibe to Ambush the soul King
interestingly it is said that he was met
with no resistance from the soul King
but the five Nobles weren't about to
take any chances here once captured they
removed all of his limbs carved out his
heart and mutilated his internal organs
before sealing him within the large
yellow Crystal where he would remain
trapped in a lifeless state for millions
of years where he was neither living nor
dead in doing so they took the power of
the Soul King for themselves and used it
to create the three Realms the world of
the living the soul society and Waco
Mundo the soul King is now held within
the Royal Palace which is guarded by an
Elite Force known as the zero division
with none other than ichibe who is
appointed this position not only as
Squad Zero's leader but the leader of
the Shinigami by the ancestors of the
five Great Noble family layers the zero
division also known as the royal guard
are made up of five members who are
tasked with the protection of the Soul
King in its secret the soul Palace
itself and the royal family the zero
division are the strongest force there
is made up of former gotai 13 captains
their total power far surpassed that of
the combined might of all the current 13
divisions altogether one of the members
oatsunamaya is actually the guy who
created the zompoc toe so there is an
example of how impressive these members
of the zero division are now we learn in
the bleach can't fear your own
world-like novel that the zero division
are all tied to the soul King Palace due
to the fact that their bones are all in
fact opens the Oaken is a special key
that grants you access to the soul King
Palace and it was the soul King's own
power that was used to modify the
members bones as oakans also because
their lives are tied to the soul King
Palace this way it means means that as
long as any one of the division members
are alive they can revive any members
that had died by simply calling out
their names not only does the Oaken act
as passageway to the soul King Palace
and a form of Revival but it also grants
the members of the zero division
agelessness ichibe stated that he had
been guarding the soul King Palace for
over a million years and I'm sure he
would look absolutely awful without the
agelessness power right now back to the
soul King so we talked about how the
soul King had his limbs removed these
dismembered Limbs and parts of the Soul
King still exist outside of the Royal
Palace exist or reincarnated into
different Souls I guess is the correct
way of putting this and they are
scattered throughout the three different
Realms the right arm of the Soul King is
called Mimi Hagi Mimi Hagi governs
Stillness as it stops the growth and
development of all things anything that
tried to change or develop could be shut
out completely by Mimi hargi now the
right arm fused with a young boy who
would later become the 13th division
Captain juiciro ukitake when he was just
three years old ukitaki developed a lung
disease a disease so bad that all the
doctors in the surrounding area gave up
and abandoned the young boy as the
illness was untreatable ukitake's
parents took their young sixth son to
the shrine of Mimi Hage and prayed that
it would take ukutake's lungs away to
which it did and this led Mimi Harge to
fuse with ukitake so that he could
survive and later become a Shinigami the
left arm of the Soul King was the
counterpart of the right arm which where
Mimi Hagi could halt change and growth
the left arm pernida governs progression
and advancement the left hand went on to
become one of yuhar Bart's sternritters
and one of the shustafel who are yuha's
Elite guard within the stern Ritter Army
now the heart of the Soul King went to
another
Stern Ritter and again shoot star form
that was none other than Gerard Valkyrie
its ability is called the miracle his
ability allows him to turn the tide of
battle and his favor through probability
manipulation the heart of the Soul King
manifests Miracles through the feelings
and desires of the user so if Gerard is
in a battle where the odds are strongly
stacked against him the miracle allows
him to succeed regardless of how bad the
situation is now fragments of the Soul
King's Soul had also ended up within the
souls of some humans which allowed them
to become fullbringers fullbringers are
humans who are spiritually aware who
possess the ability to manipulate the
souls that reside within all physical
matter I personally thought it was
amazing to find out that this is how the
fullbringers came to be and it adds more
to their background and overall story so
other fragments of the Soul King even
went to people like one of bleach's
ultimate best girl
yes bleach is so underrated when it
comes to its abundance of best girls man
anyway her fragment was stolen by none
other than Eisen who would feed said
fragment to his hokyoku so with that
knowledge on just what parts of the Soul
King can do in terms of their powers and
abilities it's clearly obvious that the
soul King is the most powerful entity in
the bleach Universe just imagine just
imagine for a second how strong this guy
was when his body was whole so it's safe
to say that the soul King are once
Transcendent being that protected the
world from Hollows and maintained a huge
lack of balance that was well and truly
needed was the originator of the
Shinigami the Quincy and the
fullbringers a man that gave up his own
life to use his powers for good only to
be thanked for his efforts by suffering
at an unthinkable and tragic fate at the
hands of the ancestors of the five Great
noble families this fate of his led to
stabilization in the world and or also
to reincarnation the soul King was
originally born into the world as a sort
of blessing to make the world a better
place but the greed of the five Noble
ancestors and ichibe led them to act out
on their own in order to create an even
better World in their own eyes this huge
information about the soul King's
backstory and nature really does expand
on the lore of the bleach universe and
also allows us to understand the motives
of the two big bads in a much more
understandable way Eisen for example
wanted the Throne of the Soul King for
himself deeming the soul King's lifeless
status as an empty Throne whereas the
soul King's son yuha bar wanted to kill
his dear father to put an end to the
current cycle of life where there would
be no fear of death these two motives
intertwine as both of these great
antagonists basically couldn't accept
the soul King as the linchpin that holds
the balance of the world together for me
it's absolutely crazy that this wasn't
included in the manga but in spin-off
light novel knowing this information
makes you understand what Eisen and yuha
bar were really after and their stories
as villains make for a much more
compelling one but you know that may
just be me so the big question on your
lips I understand you know how does
Ichigo fit into all of this well let's
talk about the fate of the Soul king and
the Thousand-Year blood War Ark yuha bar
arrives at the soul King Palace slaying
many of the Soul King's vassals before
entering the Chamber of the Soul King
himself stabbing his father straight
through the chest with his sword none
other than Ichigo arrives of course
where yuha bar tells them of the Soul
King situation and also tells them that
they are too late to do anything about
it ichigo's nature to help and protect
kicks in and he tries to help the soul
King by pulling out the sword however
his Quincy ability blood vein kicks in
which forces each go to slash the soul
King clean in half with yuhar sword
completely against his own will the
reason that this activated and took over
ichigo's movements completely was
explained by Juha ba in that it was
because of ichigo's Quincy blood the
blood of the Quincy that flows through
him cannot tolerate the existence of the
Soul King which led to it reacting on
its own to take the soul King down and
causing its death now what would happen
if the soul King were to no longer exist
well the world would begin to collapse
on itself and the balance of these three
worlds or Realms would be lost forever
but ichibe had already conceived a plan
if the unlikely event of the Soul King's
death were to occur again in the can't
fear your own Wildlife novel ichibe
reveals that both he and shinsui had
planned that in the circumstance of the
Soul King's death he would be replaced
by none other than Ichigo Kurosaki why
was Ichigo the prime candidate to
replace and be sacrificed to suffer the
same horrible never-ending fate of the
Soul King so that balance between the
three Realms would remain secured well
it was simply because of his mixed
Heritage Ichigo is not only insanely
strong himself in terms of his spiritual
power but he also has the powers of the
Soul Reapers the Quincy and the hollows
he has always stood out amongst the
crowd not because he is the Shonen
protagonist and boasts a lot of power
but because of what is arguably ichigo's
strongest power which has and always
will be his insane potential I believe
it is also within ichigo's own nature
that makes him the best candidate to be
the next Soul King ichigo's own drive
and passion to get stronger has always
been for the same singular goal to
protect even if each girl was told of
his fate you know that lifeless
existence traps for all eternity being
neither dead nor alive simply existing
for millions of years locked up in a
crystal in a never-ending tormenting
state of limbo just so that the welcome
to be saved I think he would honestly
take that it's within his own nature and
personality which again is another of
ichigo's core strengths I think even if
you show each go both sides showing him
what he would be giving up so that the
world remains protected and in balance
that he would take that responsibility
and sacrifice himself so that the world
and more importantly to Ichigo his
friends would be saved so with this plan
in motion Ichigo is trained by the zero
division during the Thousand-Year blood
War Arc while shunsui travels to the
world of the living to tell ichigo's
friends that he may never come back from
the soul Society due to him being you
know too powerful to exist in the world
of the living in shoots with actual
words it was a one in a million chance
that Ichigo would return but I believe
shunsui's words at this time were a lie
to give ichigo's friends you know
Comfort I think shinsui knew that Ichigo
was never to return and that his
training with the zero division was to
prepare Ichigo for the fact that he
would indeed become the next Soul King
and that's all thanks to the information
we got from the light novel again
however something happened that threw
ichibe's plan out in turn saving Ichigo
from what would have been a fate worse
than we could ever have possibly
imagined for our protagonist so we are
back to the events in the soul King's
Palace where each go had just sliced the
soul King clean in half without the
presence of the one keeping the world
imbalanced chaos began to ensue on the
world as it began to collapse however
ukitake took it upon himself to
sacrifice his own life to bring back
balance using Mimi Harge ukitake
sacrificed himself so that it could
stabilize the soul King saving his life
at the cost of his own in doing this a
large black hand bursts out of ukitaki
traveling straight towards the soul King
at his Palace where it grabs the upper
part of its body yuhar attempts to
destroy both Mimi hargi and the Soul
King but is stopped by Ichigo which buys
yoruichi and enough time to set up a
multiple sealed keto barrier around the
salt King she says that Mimi Hagi has
only stabilized the soul King and that
he would have to be replaced which very
well could have been Ichigo because of
each Bay's plan however yorichi is shot
in the shoulder by URI urashida which
causes her to lose concentration on her
keto barrier causing it to shatter this
sends the top half of the Soul King
flying towards yuha who rips Mimi Hagi
off of his father absorbing both Mimi
hargi and the Soul King in doing this
yuha has become the new Soul king and
the new linchpin of the world and
because Ichigo manages to defeat yuha it
is now you heart not Ichigo whose
remains are used as the new Soul King
sparing Ichigo from the Fate that comes
with the title absolutely crazy how
close we got to having Ichigo end up as
the new Soul King how would you guys
have felt about that the thought that
the knowledge we have of his happy
future with his wife Orihime and their
child together could have been nothing
more than a thought passing through the
lifeless mind of Ichigo as he wonders
about the what ifs in his sacrificed
state
bro that just makes me feel weird you
know definitely let us know in the
comment section below your thoughts on
Ichigo as the new Soul King you know
what you think about the soul King
himself and also the knowledge we got on
the soul King from the light novel
making the motivations of both Eisen and
yuhar bar seemingly much more clearer to
hers very intrigued to get your input on
these matters now if you enjoyed this
video and you'd like to see more bleach
videos on the channel make sure to let
us know by Smashing that like button if
you haven't make this the video you
subscribe and hit the notification Bell
to turn on all notifications or you will
miss future anime abroad videos while
you wait for the next bleach video to
drop on the channel make sure to check
out this hour-long video explaining all
of Ichigo kurosaki's powers and
abilities thanks again for watching and
we really can't wait to see you in the
next one till next time you take care of
yourselves